le lundi à mardi on estime que sainte
Brigitte de Laval a reçu 136 mm de pluie
en 46 heures un record pour la
municipalité l'eau est sortie de son lit
dans certains secteurs évacués lundi de
manière préventive il faut dire que
certains ici sont habitués
mais la rivière Montmorency a tout de
même atteint son plus fort débit en
matinée mardi dans les circonstances
l'état d'urgence a été décrété pas
question de laisser les 500 résidents
évacués retourner à la maison aussitôt
il annonce encore beaucoup de pluie puis
faut prévenir pour pas que le pire
arrive dans le fond en déclarant l'état
d'urgence ça permet aux citoyens de
rester plus longtemps en sécurité on a
aussi tenté de protéger des résidences
des riverains qui n'ont pas été évacuées
notre chambre à coucher est en bas
et puis on n'a pas dormi de la nuit de
peur que l'eau monte on voulait rester
ici et puis maintenant je pense qu'on
voit bien dormir cette nuit vers 16h45
le débit de la rivière Montmorency est
finalement descendu en deux ça du seuil
d'inondation mais pas de retour des
évacués avant mercredi dans la région de
Portneuf à Saint-Raymond la
crue-des-eaux à balayé certaines routes
isolant ainsi quelques centaines de
résidences et de chalets on n'a pas eu
d'évacuation encore on n'a pas eu
d'urgence encore donc on se croise les
doigts on n'a pas eu de communication de
dommages dans les maisons c'est sur
surtout les infrastructures là qui sont
défaites
ont ravivé les visions du mois de mai
dernier une digue a été creusée afin de
protéger une partie de ce terrain de
camping déjà qu'on a subi beaucoup de
dégâts avec les inondations du premier
mai nous on a pris la décision de de
faire de la protection pour éviter que
tout ce qui a été fait depuis un mois et
demi soit à recommencer encore bref une
météo qui attise les craintes liées au
changement climatique quand on parle de
changement climatique et de de de
soubresauts qui peuvent arriver ben là
je pense qu'on les vissé sous brossolo
ici qu'on est côté palettes Radio-Canada
à Sainte Brigitte de Laval